[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياد في الوقت الذي يحدث فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
مباشره من غزه في يوم احتفلت فيه حركه
المقاومه الاسلاميه حماس بالذكرى 35
لتاسيسها على واقع تهديدات لاسرائيل بشان
الاسرع
ثم بعد ذلك الى مركز
واشنطن المؤتمرات العاصمه الاداريه
الامريكيه نتابع هذه الصور من هذا البقر
في اليوم الثاني من اعمال القمه الامريكيه
الافريقيه والانشطه المقاومه على هامشي
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله ايضا
مع استمرار بالمسيرات تقارير عن ضغوط
الغربيه على جوتيرش لنشر المفتشين دوليين
في اوكرانيا واشنطن تستعد لارسال منظومه
للدفاع الجوي الى اوكرانيا رغم تهديد
الروسيه باستهدافها
وبرقيه للخارجيه الامريكيه تتحدث عن عدم
القدره على مراقبه المساعدات العسكريه
والماليه لاوكرانيا
في الذكرى الخامسه والثلاثين لتاسيس حماس
السنوار يعلن مهله قصيره لاسرائيل بهدف
اقبال صفقه تبادل الاسرار ويقول ان
الملفات لن يبقى مفتوحا الى الابد والحركه
تعرض سلاح جندي اسرائيلي اسير لديها منذ
سنوات
اتفاق الاطار في السودان على المحك
البرهان ينفي وجود تسويه سياسيه ويحذر مما
سمه محاوله لاختطاف السلطه من جديد
والاليه الثلاثيه الامميه الافريقيه تحذر
من الاقصاء السياسي وتقول ان اطرافا تعمل
على افشال الحكومه المقبله
في اول قمه الافريقيه امريكيه في عهد
اداره بايدا البيت الابيض يكشف عن
التزامات الاستثماريه وصفقات مع الدول
الافريقيه تعزيزا للشراكه ووعود بدعم
تمثيل القاره في مجموعه العشرين ووزير
الدفاع الامريكي يبدي قلقا من تزايد نفوذ
الصين وروسيا في افريقيا
وينتهمهما بعدم الشفافيه
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقم يكون قد ناقشنا معكم احتفالات احياء
الذكرى الخامسه والثلاثين لتاسيس حماس حيث
كشف رئيس الحركه في غزه يحيى سنوار عن
جوالات سريه من المفاوضات مع اسرائيل بشار
تبادل الاسرى بين الجانبين وهدد السنوار
باغلاق الملف الى الابد اذا لم تعمل
اسرائيل على اتمام صفقه بشانه قائلا لان
الاسرى الفلسطينيين ليس الحلقه الاضعف فان
بامكان المقاومه ايجاد طريقه اخرى
لتحريرهم لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
اين يتجه ملف الاسرى بين حماس واسرائيل
على ضوء تصريحات السنوار واحد 31% قالوا
ان الملف يتجه لمزيد من التعقيد بينما قال
22% انه يتجه نحو تسريع اليه تبادل الاسرى
واتوقع 47%
استمرار الوضع الحالي
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
بمسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
الرقم يتجدد يوميا تطرق خلاله لقضايا
مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
بعد الحصاد مباشره وتحديدا في الساعه
12:50 دقائق بتوقيت مكه المكرمه تتابعون
الجوله الرياضيه يوميات المونديال التي
ترصد بالخبر والتحليل مباريات كاس العالم
قطر 2022
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الاداره العسكريه لمدينه كليب ان
قوات الدفاع الجوي اسقطت مسيرات ملغمه في
احدث هجوم روسي على العاصمه الاكرانيه
واضافت ان حطام احدى الطائرات الحلقه
اضرارا بمبنيين اداريين في حي
وسط العاصمه ودعى رئيس الاداره العسكريه
في كيبورما المواطنين للبقاء في الملاج مع
استمرار الخطر
روسيا بما وصفه بمواصله ارهابي الطاقه
من جهه ثانيه قال مسؤولون امريكيون ان
واشنطن تضع اللمسات الاخيره على خطط
لتزويد اوكرانيا بصواريخ باتريوت للدفاع
الجوي واضاف المسؤولون الامريكيون ان
واشنطن قد تعلن ارساله هذه الصواريخ الى
اوكرانيا خلال الاسبوع الجاري على ايه
بتدريب الاوكرانيين على استخدامها في
قاعده للجيش الامريكي بالمانيا من جانبه
قال المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي جونكر بانه لا يمكنه تاكيد
التقارير بشان تقديم المنظومه الى
اوكرانيا خلال الحزمه المقبله من المساعده
وفي رد فعل على الاعلان الامريكي قال
مسؤولون في الكريم ان منظومات باتريوت
ستصبح بالتاكيد هدفا مشروعا للقوات
المسلحه الروسيه في حال تسليمها الى كياف
ومع الاعلان الامريكي يعودوا للحديث عن
اهميه هذه المنظومه وفعاليتها وعن مدى
احتمال تاثيرها في مجريات الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا
ما الفرق الذي قد يحدثه في الميدان تزويد
واشنطن لكياف بمنظومه الدفاع الجوي
[موسيقى]
الاحدث
منظومه الدفاع جوي ارض جو تحميل 16 صاروخا
تضاف لها مركبه الرادار وغرفه التحكم يصل
مدى الصاروخ الى نحو 70 كيلو مترا بارتفاع
اقصى اربعه وعشرون مترا يقوم نظام الرادار
الارضي الخاص بالمنظومه
في دائره قطرها 80 كم يطلق صاروخ بيتفتح
والهدف لتفجيره قبل وصوله الى وجهه
الصاروخ مجهز بنظام توجيه للمساري وتصحيحه
وهو قادر على اعتراض وتفجير الصواريخ
البالستيه وصواريخ كروز وبعض انواع
الطائرات توجد منظومه التي تعمل وفق
المسؤولين الامريكيين على تامين المجال
الجويه في اوروبا الشرقيه ومنها رومانيا
وبولندا كما توجد المنظومه في دول اوروبيه
اخرى كالمانيا وهولندا واسبانيا وسائل
اعلام امريكيه ذكرت اخيرا قد تصل الى
اوكرانيا في وقت قريب لكن وضعها في
المعركه قد يحتاج الى وقت اطول نظرا
للحاجه الى تدريب الاوكرانيين على
استخدامها الامر الذي قد يستغرق من وجهه
نظرهم اشهر بكاملها
افاده
عن برقيه لوزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
اداره ايضا تواجهه صعوبات بتتبع مال
المساعدات الماليه والعسكريه التي تقدم
لاوكرانيا وسطها دعوات متزايده لتعزيز
الرقابه على الاموال وكذلك على الاسلحه
واشارت برقيه الخارجيه الامريكيه الى ان
المسؤولينا يلجئون الى كل التقنيات
المتاحه لتتبع مليارات الدولارات المقدمه
لاوكرانيا بحسب الصحيفه واوردت الصحيفه ان
واشنطن تخططه للاستفاده من شركه امريكيه
لتنفيذ مبادره مدتها ثلاث سنوات للمساعده
في جهود الرقابه وقد قدمت الولايات
المتحده لاوكرانيا لمساعده ماليه وعسكريه
تتجاوز ثمانيه واربعين مليار دولار منذ
بدايه حرب روسيا وفق احصائيات غير رسميه
وينضم الينا من جنب رئيس تحرير المجال
العسكريه السويسريه
فيما يتعلق بهذا الكلام عن تسليم اوكرانيا
للبتروتو هذا التحذير الروسي هل ترجح ان
يتم تسليم انظمه باتريوت الى اوكرانيا
وما يطلبه الاوكرانيون هو منظمات الدفاع
الجوي للحفاظ والحمايه على البنى التحتيه
والمدن الاوكرانيه وبالتالي بكل تاكيد
هناك صواريخ متعدده تتجه باتجاه اوكرانيا
هناك اسلحه متعدده وفي نهايه المطاف على
الارجح منظومه سوف ترسل لانها الوحيده
التي تصنع في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
للصواريخ بعيده المدى هذه المنظومه تحتاج
الى وجود خبراء امريكيين معها ماذا عن
وجوده هؤلاء الخبراء في داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ومواقع تقول روسيا بانها سوف
تستهدفها
منذ الرابع والعشرين من شباط فبراير اي
منذ بدايه هذا النزاع المسلح الدول
الاوروبيه من مثل المانيا
ودول البلطيه قامت بتنظيمي مراكز وتشكيل
مراكز للتدريب للاوكرانيين المتخصصين في
جهازي المدفعيه الى اخره وبالتالي لا
اعتقد ان الحاجه تبرز الى وجود مدربين
امريكيين او من بلدان النيت على الاراضي
الاوكرانيات كيف وجدت هذا التهديد من قبل
الجانب الروسي بانه سوف يضرب هذه
المنظومه اذا في هذه الحاله
هيبقى لي بيتزا
الروس اولا سوف يحاولون ان يدمر منظومات
هذه لان لذلك قيمه رمزيه كبرى ولكن السؤال
يطرح هل باستطاعه روسيا القيام بذلك اعتقد
ان احتمال ان تتمكن من الخام بذلك ومنخفض
للغايه فيها القوات الروسيه تمكنت من
القضاء على اقل من ثلث المنظمات الدفاعيه
الاوكرانيه ونحن نتحدث عن التكنولوجيا
تعود الى الثمانيات والتسعينيات من القرن
الماضي اي منظومات قديمه والروسي يعرفونها
بشكل واضح وكبير لماذا لم يتمكن الروس من
القضاء على هذه المنظمات الدفاعيه الجويه
اولا ليس لديهم قدره على ارسال الطائرات
المتخصصه في هذا المجال روسيا تستخدم
الطائرات الحربيه العاديه والقنابل
والصواريخ العاديه وبالتالي التكلفه
مرتفعه ولا تتمكن من القضاء ومن تدمير
المنظومات وخصوصا اذا ما كانت منظومات
دفاعيه حديثه وايضا سوف يكونوا من الصعوبه
بمكان بالنسبه الى روسيا ان تدمر هذه
المنظمات
لان منظومه ليست المنظومه الوحيده التي هي
موجوده في مواجهه الاخوه الروسيه لو كانت
لوحدها كان لربما بس تعطيها ان تقوم بذلك
ولكن
كوينتي فين ما يتعلق بما نقلته صحيفه
بوليتكو عن ان الاداره الخلي او الخارجيه
الامريكيه تفتح ربما هناك ملف يتعلق
بالمساعدات تقدم لي الجانب الاخراني
والحديث عن تشكيل هيئه للرقابه اين يتم
صرفه لتذهب هذه الاموال كيف وجد هذا
المؤشر
للاسلحه لبيع الاسلحه تم توقيع عليها من
قبل عدد كبير من البلدان ولم تصادق عليها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه النقطه
الثانيه هي ان هناك قلق على مستوى السياسي
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حول
الاسلحه التي فقدت او اصبحت في ايدي العدو
في افغانستان او في سوريا ولكن الوضع
يختلف بشكل جذريا هنا نحن نتحدث عن حرب في
اوكرانيا لا اعتقد ان هذه الحاله يمكن ان
تقرا
شكرا لكم
رئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه السويسريه
رفيع العرض التالي على ابرز منظومه الدفاع
الجوي التي تسلمتها كاف من دول اوروبيه
[موسيقى]
نقل موقع اكس يوصل الاخباريه عن مصادر بان
هناك ضغوط الغربيه على الامين العام للامم
المتحده
اوكرانيا للتحقق من استخدام روسيا لمسيرات
ايرانيه الصنع فيها هجماتها على العاصمه
كيف ومدن الاوكرانيه اخرى في وقت ترفض فيه
روسيا
لمجلس الامن في هذا الاتجاه واورد موقع
اكسيوس ان هذه التطورات تتزامل مع اصدار
تقرير الامم خاص بتقيم بدمتثال ايران
للاتفاق النووي ولكن مع خلوه من اي اشارات
او التهابات لطهران بتزويد موسكو بمسيرات
تستخدم في الحرب باوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
بعد ساعات بالفشل وزراء الطاقه الاوروبيين
في الاتفاق على تحديد سقف لاسعار الغاز
قال المستشار الالماني
لا توجد حلول الفوريه بسيطه لمساله الطاقه
ولا يمكن التدخل في الاسعار
واعلن في كلمه امام البرلمان الالماني
البردستاني
البحث من خلال يا حزمه 200 مليار يورو
تبدا الحكومه الفدراليه كل ما في وسعها
لمواجهه تداعيات الحرب العدواني الروسيه
من اجل تسهيل الوضع على المواطنين
في قضايا الطاقه لقد اتفقنا على اهداف
مخزونات مشتركه واتفقنا على اننا سنخفف من
ارتفاع اسعار الكهرباء نحن نعمل على شراء
الغاز بشكل جماعي حتى نتمكن من ملئ
خزاناتنا جيدا للعام المقبل من الواضح انه
لا توجد حلول الفوريه وبسيطه
عينك
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسلها بندر
لاين
انقطاع الغاز الروسيه اثر على الوضع
الاقتصادي وادى الى ارتفاع الاسعار
وارتفاعه تكلفه الانتاج بالنسبه للشركه
للغاز الى اوروبا لكننا قادرون على
تعويضها فقد نوعنا مصادر الطاقه واقتصادنا
ولجئنا الى الطاقه المتجدده وقلصنا من
ارباح الكبيره للشركات وحاولنا حمايه
الشركات والبيوت المهدده والتفقنا على
الشراء الجماعي وقررنا تحديدا سقف الاسعار
المخازن ممتلئه وهذا يعني اننا مستعدون
وامنون هذا الشتاء لكن كل هذا له الثمن
فالامدادات غير مكلف انتهت بسبب السياسه
الروسيه ولن تعود وفي غياب الغاز الروسي
تواجه اوروبا اسعارا اكبر والبديل الوحيد
هو تامين الانتقال الى الطاقه المتجدده
وهي ليست فقط غير مكلفه ولكنها تنتج على
ارضنا لكن ذلك لا يتم بين عشيه وضحاها
سنعود الى ملف الطاقه يتوقف عند اهم
الخلافات التي تحول دون الوصول الاتفاق
بشان تسعير الغاز
[موسيقى]
اقامت حركه حماس مهرجان الجماهيريا في غزه
بمناسبه الذكرى الخامسه والثلاثون
لتاسيسها وجهت خلالها رسائل عده اعاده
التاكيد على ثوابت وطنيه تجاه قضايا تشغل
الشارع الفلسطيني ودعا يحيى السنوار رئيس
حركه حماس في قطاع غزه السلطه الفلسطينيه
لوقف التنسيق الامنيه مع اسرائيل وامهل
السنوار الاحتلال وقتا محددا لاتمام صفقه
تبادل الاسرى وتحدث عن استحقاقات الوطنيه
كبرى في العام المقبل
[موسيقى]
كثيره هي الرسائل التي حملها احتفال حركه
حماس في الذكرى الخامسه والثلاثين
الانطلاقتها
[موسيقى]
فقد كان مناسبه للتاكيد على ثوابت الحركه
رغم كل التحديات التي اعترضت مسيرته
[موسيقى]
لكن قائد الحركه في قطاع غزه يحيى السنوار
او لهتماما ملموسا لقضيه الاسرى عندما كشف
عن فشل جولات مفاوضات سريه مع اسرائيل
لاتمام صفقه جزئيه لتبادل الاسرى تكون
مقدمه لصفقه شامله على غرار صفقه شاليه
[موسيقى]
وقتا محدودا لاكمال هذه
اخر العدو الاربعه طرف المقاومه الى ابد
الابدين
وبغرض تحريك ملف اسرع عرضت وحده الظل
التابعه لكتائب القسام قطعه سلاح قالت
انها لضابط اسرائيلي اثرته خلال حرب عام
2014 هذه
وبخلاف كثير من الرسائل التي وجهها
السنوار لاطراف خارجيه وداخليه فقد حذر من
تحديات الاستراتيجيه كبرى ستعترض مسيره
الشعب الفلسطيني خلال العام المقبل قال
انه لا سبيل لمواجهتها الا بالوحده
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه وهو المطلب نفسها الذي
تضمنته كلمه صوتيه مسجله لقائد كتائب
القسام
وتلتئم كل الجبهات والتفتح كل الساحات
لهدف واحد غايه كبيره نبيله مقدسه وهي
تحرير فلسطين رسائل حركه حماس ومطالبها
تاتي في ظل مرحله حساسه وتطورات محليه
واقليميه متوتره
فالاوضاع في القدس والضفه الغربيه تبدو
مرشحه للتصعيد بفعل السياسه الاسرائيليه
تجاه الفلسطينيين هنا
وفي ضوء هذه الاوضاع يترقب كثيرون طبيعه
التطورات الميدانيه في المرحله المقبله
والى الدحدوح الجزيره غزه فلسطين
معنا من القدس رونيه شديد الكاتب الصحفي
السيد روني رسائل عده وجه السنوار اليوم
العالمي من ابرازها ان حماس تمهل اسرائيل
مده قصيره فيما يتعلق بملف تبادل الاسرى
وانها فانها سوف تنجي هذا الملف بشكل
نهائي
اهلا وسهلا بكم
احتفال هذه هي الرسائل للاحتفال الي هي
للشعب الفلسطيني في غزه طول الشعب
الاسرائيلي والجزر الحكومه الاسرائيليين
الجديده
اسمع اسمع كويس طيب اذا كانت مجرد رسائل
صوتيه اذا لماذا الدخول في تفاوض سري مع
حماس كل هذه الفتره الماضيه
بالنسبه
لاسرائيل برده الشروط والمره هذه الشروط
الاسرائيليه هي برده
عده فلسطينيين من الحماس اللي موجودين
بالسجن الاسرائيلي ولا واحد في اسرائيل
زي ما انا قلت لك المفاوضات راح تستمر
وعشر سنوات
عشر سنوات
اكيد سبق للحكومه الاسرائيليه ان تكلمت
حكومه طبعا سابقه ان تكلمت بنسبه تتكلم به
الان ولكننا شاهدنا في الماضي صفقه لتبادل
معه هنا تحديدا عن صفقه همم شريط وبالتالي
هناك سوابق اذا ما الذي يمنعها الان ان
تتكرر اذا كان الكلام مجرد دعايه صوتيه
كما تقول
رئيس الوزراء جديد
يعني ما بعرف دائما انا شايف ان الشعب
الاسرائيلي الاغلبيه الشعب الاسرائيلي تدل
سابكيلي كانت ايام شبيبه الصفقه اللي كانت
ايام شبيكه ده كان ضد اسرائيل واليوم ناس
بيفهموا ان هذا كان غلط كثير من من ناحيه
رئيس الوزراء اللي سوا اللي همم الصفقه
هذه اما لا بد لازم يصير صفقه انا ما بعرف
صفكه اما لازم يصير صفقه بالنسبه للثمن
الاسرائيلي والثمن الاسرائيلي اللي لازم
يكون هذا ما لازم يكون 10 موجودين بالسجن
بجوز بجوز
ناس بيسووا عمليات تخربيه موجودين اليوم
في اسرائيل
قال لك ايه كنت معي من القدس وروني شكيدا
الكاتب الصحفي الاسرائيلي
ارحب بضيفي من غزه مصطفى صواف الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي مصطفى اقف معك عندما قاله
السيد سوار هذا اليوم الرسائل التي حاولت
حماس ايصالها في هذه المناسبه خاصه ما
تعلق منها
بصفقه تبادل الاسرى ما الذي ربما دفع
بحماس الى تحديد هذه المغلى في ظل الحديث
عن تفاوض سري فشل حتى الان
نعم هذا التفاؤل جرى قبل الانتخابات
الصهيونيه في القاهره بين حماس والاحتلال
الصهيوني واعتقد ان ما قدمته حماس لم يقنع
الاحتلال لان الاحتلال لا زال يكذب على ان
الجنديين شاؤول وجولدن هم جثث وهذا الامر
لا تعلمه الا حماس وعندما تحدث السنوار عن
وجود اربعه اسره هذه فيها مؤشرات كبيره
ولذلك هذا الفشل هو الذي دفعه حركه حماس
الى القول بانها ستمه للاحتلال وقتا قليلا
ثم تطوي هذا الملف الى ابد الابدين
والاحتلال بكل تاكيد حتى هذه اللحظه مع
الاسد لم يتحرك الجمهور الصهيوني للضغط
على حكومه الاحتلال كما حدث في صفقه وفاء
الاحرار او صفقه شريط ولذلك المطلوب الان
هو تحريك الراي العام الصهيوني للضغط على
الحكومه القادمه او اي حكومه تحكم هذا
الكيان وهذه مساله تحتاج الى مزيد من
العمل واعتقد ان لدى القسام ما يمكن ان
يقدمه في هذا الموضوع كما حدث ايضا اليوم
عندما
جاء في كلمه يحيى السنوار يثم يتعلق بهذا
الملف تحديدا باعتقادك ما الكلمات
المفتاحيه التي ربما سيكون لها هذا
التاثير اذا كان المستهدف بالاساس هو
الجمهور الاسرائيلي من اجل الضغط على
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ما الكلمات المفتاحيه
باعتقادك
يا سيدي عندما يقول استثمار بان حكومه
الاحتلال هي التي افشلت هذا ال اييي هذه
الصفقه بسبب عين عدها وبسبب امور كثيره
اعتقد ان اغلاق الملف قد يكون هو المفتاح
الذي ربما يحرك هذا الجمهور ولكن ايضا
يحتاج الى مفاتيح اخرى تقدمها كتائب
القسام كما قدمت اليوم مفتاح ربما يكون
فيه شيئا ما سيحرك هذا الكيان اعتقد ان
هذا هو الذي كان يسعى اليه معه السنوار في
خطابه وفي تاكيده على ان هناك جهود كبيره
من قبل حماس في نجل تحرير الاصل
فيما يتعلق بتوقيت هذا الاعلان من قبل
حماس وتحديد هذه المهله ومعطى الحكومه
القادمه في اسرائيل توصف بانها الاكثر
يمينيه والاكثر تطرفا
يزيد كما قلت قبل قليل ان من اجرا صفقه
وفاء الاحرار او صفقه
لذلك لا يوجد في تلك الفتره التي كان فيها
لبيد وبنت اي شخصيه قويه يمكن ان تحقق ما
تسعى اليه او ما تريد حركه حماس او يتحمل
مسؤوليه اجراء صفقه تبادل جديده حتى هذه
اللحظه كما قلنا ان الاحتلال لا زال يضل
الجمهوره بان هناك جنديان هم عباره عن جثث
ولكن هذه الامور لا يعلمها الا حماس وهذه
مساله اعتقد انها في غايه الوضوء اعتقد ان
الوقت الان خاصه ان هذا المهرجان فيه كثير
من الرسائل التي ارسلت الى القيام وكذلك
الى غير الكيان واعتقد ان هذه الرسائل
كانت
مدروسه بشكل جيد من قبل حركه حماس وعلى
الاحتلال ان يفهم ما ارسلته حركه حماسيه
ماذا عن رساله الاشاره الى ان العام
القادم سيكون صعبا الدلو هذا ربما ما
انعكس بشكل او باخر على تدخل المقاومه في
اكثر من من مفصل ماذا عن هذه النقطه
واهميتها
يا سيدي اعتقد ان هذا العام قد ولا وان
لدى حركه حماس استراتيجيه معينه او هدف
تريد تحقيق وهي تاكد بان عام 2023 قد يكون
عاما فيه من الخطوره الكبيره التي يفكر
فيها الاحتلال بشان عدوان على قطاع غزه او
الضفه الغربيه او غزه والضفه الغربيه وهذه
مساله تاكد واكد فيها السنوار بان
المقاومه الفلسطينيه والراسها حماس على
استعداد تام لاراد اي عدوان قبل الاحتلال
ان لديها من الصواريخ اضعاف من مكانه
لديها في السابق
شكرا لك من غزه مصطفى الصواف الكاتب هو
المحلل الاسياسي
[موسيقى]
في السودان اعلن رئيس مجلس السياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان ان القوات المسلحه لن
توافقه في مرحله الاتفاق النهائي للعمليه
السياسيه على اي بنود يمكن ان تنال من
ثوابت البلاد بحسب تعبيره وفي اشاره
للاتفاق الايطاليه الذي وقع في الخامس من
الشهر الجاري قال البرهان في خطاب امام
افراد من القوات المسلحه انه ليس هناك
تسويه سياسيه بالمعنى الذي يفهمه البعض
عايز اسمع تسويه
نشوف ان هذه النقاط او هذه الاموره
وفي ردود الفعل اعتبر القيادي في الحريه
والتغيير المجلس المركزي ياسر عرفان ان في
تغريده على تويتر ان رئيس مجلس السياده
بالسودان عبد الفتاح البرهان اعاد في
خطابه الاخير المشهد في البلاد الى ما قبل
الاتفاق الايطالي مشيرا الى تدخل الجيش في
تشكيل الحكومه القادمه وان الحكومه
البدنيه ذات سلطه كليه بعد الانتخابات
واضاف علما ان
اتفاق الايطالي حدد الاطراف المدنيه
ودورها بدقه بموافقه العسكريين يشكل حديث
البرهان اليوم تراجع عن الاتفاق وعن محتوى
العمليات السياسيه
من جهتي حضر الناطق باسم الاليه ثلاثيه
ممثله الاتحاد الافريقي بالسودان محمد
بلعيش من ان بعض الاطراف في السودان تهدد
باسقاط الحكومه القادمه قبل تشكيلها واصفا
ذلك بانه امر مخجل وحذر مما سماه الاقصى
السياسيه
اليوم
من كلامه
لا احد يريد الانتخابات لا احد كذلك يريد
ان يمد يده الى الاخر
انك تريد اسقاط الحكومه قبل تشكيلها
في التقرير التالي نقترب اكثر من مضمون
هذا الاتفاق
وقع ما عرف بالاتفاق الايطالي في الخرطوم
يوم الخميس من ديسمبر الجاري وكانت
الاطراف التي وقعت عليه تامل ان يكون
بدايه الحل لانسداد السياسي الذي يمر به
السودان شمل الاتفاق اكثر من مستوى فنصت
بنوده على ابعاد الجيش عن اي عمل سياسي
ودمج قوات الدعم السريع بالقوات المسلحه
ومن اي تشكيل اي ميليشيا عسكريه او ما
يشابهها يدخل السودان بموجب الاتفاق فتره
الانتقاليه لعامين تبدا من تعيين رئيس
الوزراء تختارهما تطلق على نفسها قوه
الثوره وعليه ستكون السلطه الانتقاليه
مكونه من مجلس تشريعي ومستوى سيادي ومجلسا
للوزراء خلال الفتره الانتقاليه ستناقش
صياغه دستور للبلاد ثم تنظم عمليه
انتخابيه شامله في نهايه الفتره
الانتقاليه تم الاتفاق على تاجيل مناقشه
بعض البنود وهي العداله الانتقاليه
والاصلاح الامني عسكري واتفاق جوبا للسلام
وتفكيك نظام الرئيس السابق عمر البشير
الاطراف الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطاري مع
المجلس السيادي ابرزها حزب الامه القومي
والمؤتمر السوداني والتجمع لاتحادي
والمؤتمر الشعبي وانصار السنه اما ابرز
المقاطعين الاتفاق فهم الكتله الديمقراطيه
والاتحادي الاصل والتيار الاسلامي العريض
والحزب الشيوعي ولجان المقاومه بالخرطوم
ولهؤلاء المقاطعين اسباب منها رفض التفاوض
والشراكه مع الجيش كما وصف بعض رافضين
الاتفاق بانه ثنائي واقصائي وادى الى
انشقاقات داخليه
الخرطوم مرحب بيتي يا سيد محمد المبروك
الصحفي والمحلل السياسي اهلا بك سيد محمد
كيف تجد المشهد حاليا بعد هذه التصريحات
بدايه من تصريحات السيد البرهان وردود
الفعل عليها بما في ذلك ممثل الثلاثيه
والاتحاد الافريقي هنا اعني مصير الاتفاق
الايطالي
الجيش اليوم في المعاقين فيه استعاده خطاب
25 اكتوبر الذي مرت عليه مر عليه عام كامل
ولكن همم ما هو واضح ان ان القوه السياسيه
تتعامل مع الوضع السياسي في السودان
والمشهد السياسي السوداني الحالي وتركيبته
ومعطياته الحاليه وكانه وهو ذات المشهد
السياسي في ابريل 2019 وهذا غير صحيح
البته وغير واقع يعني الواقع السياسي بعد
عام من 25 اكتوبر قد تغير تماما
المنظومه الامنيه وعلى راسها سيد البرهان
دعامات قيام وتشكيل همم مكونات سياسيه كتل
سياسيه
وبالنسبه لكل المراقبين مفهوم جدا انها
حليفه للجيش فكيف تتوقع الحريه والتغيير
الجسم الذي وقع على الاتفاق الايطالي في
خمسه ديسمبر ان يتخلل برهان كل السهوله عن
حلفاءه يعني بهؤلاء الحلفاهم قتل الكتله
الديمقراطيه الحريه والتغير كل
الديمقراطيه وايضا كتله نداء اهل السودان
الذي تشمل في داخلها قوى محافظه وبعض
الاسلاميين خطاب اليوم هو تطنين لهذه
الكتل التي بدات تتخوف مؤخرا من الاتفاق
الثنائي بين الحريه والتغيير ومجلس
السياده التطميل لها بان همم بان الجيش
بان قياده الجيش لن تتخلى عنها هل هو
استدراك
من قبل السيد البرهان والا فما الذي تم
عندما تم الاعلام عن الاتفاق الاطاري
انا اتفق تماما مع مقاله السيد البرهان
بان هناك من فهم الاتفاق الايطار بصوره
خاطئه ووو ووقع في فخ ان ال ال الاستحواذ
على على الكره بلغه اليوم يعني بالفعل
اتفاق الايطالى اعطى الكره للحريه
والتغيير الحريه والتغيير يفترض انها كان
تتجه بهذه بهذه المعطى الذي اوجدته بين
يديها لفتحه لي التوافق الكامل بين كل
القوه السياسيه بحيث انها تشكل جبهه واسعه
حول هذا الاتفاق ولكن الحصل انه الحريه
والتغيير وخاصه في المرحله الاخيره خاصه
بعض الاختبار الذي وضعه فيها السيد مبارك
الفاضل حينما اعلن بانه سيوقع على الاتفاق
واصدره عدد من مكونات الحريه والتغيير
بيانات بيانات ترفض ان يوقع ما مبارك
ايضا يشمل ممثل الثلاثيه والا الافريقي هو
ايضا علق وقال وسمعت مقال
طيب جميل جدا انا برده هاقول لك بنفس
المعنى في ذات السياق انه مجلس الامن
الدولي في بيان امس تحدث عن ضروره فتح
الاتفاق وضروره خراط القوى السياسيه
الاخرى وهي بالذات الكتله الديمغرافيه
وربما جزء من نداء اهل السودان في هذا
الاتفاق مجلس الامن اصدر هذا البيان وكان
واضح جدا وبدا لليوم ان خطاب قائد الجيش
يتفق تماما مع وجهه مع بيان مجلس الامن
فائد الجيش تحدث عن ماذا تحدث عن فتح
الاتفاق عن ضروره عدم الاخصاء انا كبير
قلت انه هو استعاده لقطاع 25 اكتوبر لانه
25 اكتوبر بانيت سياسيا على فتح الله
العمليه السياسيه وعن التوافق السياسي او
على توثيق قاعده الانتقال ما حدث خلال
الفتره من خمسه ديسمبر وحتى اليوم ان بعض
الغوه السياسيه التي هي طرف انت تبقى خمسه
ديسمبر بدل تتحدث وكانما هي الوحيده في
المشهد السيا سوداني وهذا ما افسد هذه
الطبخه التي يفترض انها تصل لاتفاق
النهائي هناك حاجه مهمه جدا او شيء مهم
جدا في هذه في مساله العمليه السياسيه
الحاليه العمليه السياسيه ليست نهايتها
الاتفاق الايطالي الاتفاق الايطالي هو
بدايه للعمليه السياسيه يفترض انه هناك
مساحه كامله وعمليه سياسيه كبيره بين
الاتفاق الايطار والاتفاق النهائي هناك
شيء اسمه الاتفاق النهائي نحن لم نصل له
بعد وقبل ان نصل له بدانا في همم التعامل
وكانك الكره في ملعبنا نحن بالكامل
التغيير وهذا هو الخطا ولا اعتقد ان خطاب
البرهان خارج عن هذه السياق شكرا لك من
الخرطوم محمد المبروك الصحفي والمحلل
السياسي
[موسيقى]
تعلم الرئيس الامريكي عن استثمارات
امريكيه جديده في افريقيا
في افريقيا ضروري لبناء اقتصاد العالمي
قويه
لزياده دور الاتحاد
له في مجموعته دول العشرين
[موسيقى]
التجاره تعتمد على اغنيه
سلاسل
رؤيتنا لبناء اقتصاد عالميا قوي قادر على
تحمل صدمات كتلك التي شهدناها في السنوات
القليله الماضيه
العيد
في افريقيا بشكل مستمر جاء ذلك على هامش
القمه الامريكيه الافريقيه الثانيه التي
تندرج في اطار سياسي عالميا خاص
افريقيا في ضيافه واشنطن يريد الامريكيون
تنشيط العلاقات مع القاره السمراء ولذلك
جاء في معظم قادتها الى القمه الثانيه من
نوعها بين الجانبين خلال ثمانيه اعوام قد
تكون رسالته هنا ان الولايات المتحده لم
تسقط افريقيا من لائحه اهتماماتها وهي
احرس ما تكون الان على تطبيق استراتيجيه
جديده
المتراجع في القاره لمصلحه روسيا والصين
الشعبيه
في افريقيا
كده ستؤدي في النهايه الى زعزعه الاستقرار
هذا اذا لم يكن ذلك قد حصل بالفعل
تتهموا النخبه الامريكيه الصينيين من
الخراط في ممارسات تجاريه تصفها بغير
العادله في الجغرافيا الافريقيه الغنيه
بالموارد الطبيعيه كما لا يروق لتلك
النخاب ما تعتبره تعاونا عسكريا وامليا
مشبوها يربط الروس بدول افريقيا
اكبر موارد للاسلحه في افريقيا
واسعا في القاره من خلال المشاركات
الامنيه
بالمباراه
55 مليار دولار من المساعدات الافريقيه
على مدى ثلاثه اعوام لاستماله المترددين
من الشركاء الافارقه الى صفها
يوضح الامريكيون انهم لن يخيروا دول
الافريقيه بينهم وبين الصينيين والروس
اولئك الذين تصفوا واشنطن
بالمزعزعه للاستقرار في افريقيا
ليس في افريقيا وحدها يتحرك منافسه واشنطن
مدفوعين بحسابات الاقتصاديه وجيو سياسيه
في المنطقه العربيه الساعيه لتنويع
انشطتها الاقتصاديه تتحرك الصين بوتيره
متسارعه
في المنطقه لفت الانظار الى بلاده
اخرى للتعاون التجاري والاقتصادي
والتكنولوجي فضلا عن المجالات السياسيه
والعسكريه البيت الابيض راى في الامر
مثالا على محاولات الصين كما قال لبست
نفوذها في انحاء العالم
وبشرى روسيا قال اوسطن مين موسكو تبيعه
الاسلحه للمتحاربين في افريقيا وتوظف
المرتزقه فيها وختم بان ممارسات روسيا
والصين تزحزح والاستقرار في افريقيا
التي تقوم بها روسيا والصين مثيره
للاهتمام وبالتاكيد اعتقد ان تاثير
البلدين يمكن ان يكون مزعزا عن الاستقرار
في افريقيا
تعقد القمه الافريقيه الامريكيه تنضم
الينا مراسلات الجزيره وجد وقفي وجد ماذا
عن مجريات هذه
القمه هل لدى انطباعه واشنطن بانها وصلت
هذه المره متاخره بالنظر الى ما قالته على
التغلغل الروسي وكذلك الصيني في افريقيا
هي ايه لا شك وصلت متاخره عن الصين وروسيا
ولكن كانت هي المبادره في عام 2014 خلال
العهد اوباما وكما نذكر عندما جاء الرئيس
ترامب هو لم يبتعد فقط بامريكا عن القاره
الافريقيه بل انه في احد تصريحاته ازدراء
القاره الافريقيه هذا الابتعاد خلال
الحقبه الماضيه همم فسح المجال لكل من
الصين وروسيا من وجهه نظر الاداره
الامريكيه الحاليه فسح المجال لهما
ببسط هاي ملاتهما ونفوضهما على القاره
الافريقيه وهذا هو ما تحاول اداره بيجن
التقليص من تاثيراته على افريقيا وبالتالي
هي اليوم تدخل فصلا جديدا في التنافس
الصيني الامريكي الروسي على القاره
الافريقيه من خلال هذه القمه ولكن حقيقه
هذه القمه همم تقدم بعضا من ال القضايا
التي تساعد القاره الافريقيه
كمثلا كما ذكر الرئيس لدى كلمته اليوم
اتفاق التجاره حره بين الولايات المتحده
وافريقيا هذا الاتفاق هو بوصفه تاريخي
لانه الاول من نوعه وكذلك هناك حزمه من
المساعدات الاقتصاديه وكذلك الامنيه
للقاره الافريقيه سوف تقدمها الولايات
المتحده للاتحاد الافريقي خلال هذه القمه
هناك حديث عن مجمل هذه المساعدات بحسب
مستشار الرئيس الامريكي ليصل الى 55 مليار
دولار رئيس بايدن همم تحدث عن سياسه
الاداره الامريكيه التي تعتمد على التقارب
من خلال تبادل التجاري من خلال الاستث في
البنيه التحتيه وكما قال الرئيس الامريكي
لا يوجد تجاره ولتبادل تجاري من بو- من
دون بنيه تحتيه قويه كذلك سوف تركز هذه
الشراكه ما بين الولايات المتحده والاتحاد
الافريقي على التعاون الامني وفي هذا
الاطار اعلن الرئيس بيدن عن ان شركه سيسكو
الامريكيه سوف توفر مساعدات
لدرع هجمات الكترونيه عن بعض الدول
الافريقيه قيمتها 800 مليون دولار هناك
اذا الكثير من مجالات التنميه كلها كما
ذكرت عبد القادر تهدف الى منافسه الصين
وروسيا روسيا التي تتمها الولايات المتحده
على لسان وزيري دفاعها بالمترجمه بالسلاح
الرخيص على حد وصفي في القاره الافريقيه
وكذلك تقديم مرتزقه لتغطيه الحروب داخل
القاره هذا هو التاثير
روسي الذي تحاول الاداره الحاليه درقه
وايضا التاثير الصيني يختصر في الهيمه
الاقتصاديه الصينيه على افريقيا
الافريقيه من واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
قالت الحكومه البريطانيه ان اربعه اشخاص
لقوا مصرعهم كما تمكنت سلطاته من انقاذ
اكثر من 40 من طالب اللجوء كانوا على
متقارب غارقه في بحر المانش فجر اليوم ومن
جهاتها قالت وزيره الداخليه
انها تتابعوا الحادثه الذي وصفته بالمزعج
كما افاد مسؤولون بالحكومه واداره الطوارئ
ان الطوارئ النجاه وطائرات الهليكوبتر
وفرق الانقاذ تعمل بالتعاون مع القوات
البحريه الفرنسيه للتعامل مع حادث الغرق
لقد عبر رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي
سوناك عن حزنه لحادثه غرق اربعه مهاجرين
في القناه الانجليزيه و خلال المساءله
الاسبوعيه في البرلمان البريطاني جدد
تاكيده على منع تهريب المهاجرين الى
بريطانيا باي شكل موضحا ان حكومته بصدد
صياغه تشريع جديد في هذا الشهر
الجديد
من حق البقاء فيها وستتم اعادته الى بلده
الاصلي او الى اي بلد اخر امن هذا هو
النظام الذي يريده الشعب البريطاني وهذا
ما سنفعله
اعلن قالت هي احتياطي في الامريكيه رفع
سعر الفائده بمعدل نصف نقطه مئويه ليصل
الى اربعه ونصف في المئه وافادت وسائل
اعلام الامريكيه ان سعر الفائده سجل بذلك
اعلى مستوى له منذ 15 عاما من جهته قال
رئيس الاحتياطي الفيدرالي الامريكي جيروم
باول ان هذه الخطوه تاتي في سياق الجهود
لخفض نسبه التضخم واعادها الى اثنين في
البيئه مع الوقت واضاف باول الا ان في
مؤتمر الصحفي ان سوق العمل لا يزال غير
متوازن اذ يتجاوز الطلب على العماله تلك
المعروضه بشكل كبير مضيفا ان الحربه
الروسيه على اوكرانيا ادت لارتفاع اسعار
الطاقه والغذاء وساهمت في زياده التضخم
وتعليقا على ملف ترسيم الحدود البحريه
الليبيه دعت حكومه فتحي بشاره وهو رئيس
الحكومه المكلف من مجلس النواب دعت حكومه
مصر وتركيا واليونان الى عدم اتخاذ اي
خطوات احاديه من شانها زياده التوتر
وتئزين المواقف في منطقه البحر المتوسط
وقالت حكومه باشا انها على استعداد
للتفاوض الثنائي مع هذه الدول من اجل
ترسيم الحدود البحريه بما يخدم المصالح
المشتركه العادله للجميع وياتي البيان
الليبي بعد يومين بالاصدار الرئيس المصري
قرارا بتحديد حدود مصر البحريه مع ليبيا
ونشره في الجريده الرسميه
سددها وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني
بلانك من خلال لقائه الرئيسه التونسي قائد
سعيد في واشنطن على اهميه اجراء انتخابات
برلمانيه حره ونزيه في السابعه عشر من
ديسمبر فضلا عن اصلاحات شامله لتعزيز
الضوابط والتوازنات الديمقراطيه وحمايه
الحريات الاساسيه مشددا على ان العلاقه
بين الجانبين تكون اقوى عندما يكون هناك
التزام مشترك بالديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان
وجدد لينك للالتزام الولايات المتحده
العميق بالديمقراطيه تونسيه ودعم تطلعات
الشعب التونسي الى مستقبل ديمقراطيه مزدهر
واكد لينكن دعم الولايات المتحده القوي
للاقتصادي التونسي وسط الازمه الاقتصاديه
الحاليه من جريده قال الرئيس التونسي خلال
لقائه مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ان
الدستور تمت صياغته بعد ثوره كان مصمما
لتلبيه احتياجات فئه معينه
راس سيد الى ان هذه الفرصه جيده للحديث عن
الروابط التي تجمع البلدين
[موسيقى]
نعود الى ازمه الطاقه في العالم فقد تتحكم
انتظار ايام اخرى لتوافق على اليه لتحديد
سقف لاسعار الغاز بالجمله فهل ستكون هذه
المهلكه كافيه لدول الاتحاد الاوروبي
لتجاوزي خلافاتها المفوضيه الاوروبيه كانت
قد اقترحت في البدايه تشغيل اليه لتحديد
السقفه تلقائيا بمجرد تجاوز الاسعار
275 يورو للمقاوات ساعه لمده اسبوعين
متتاليين بشرط ان تكون اعلى بما لا يقل عن
58 يورو من متوسطه السعر المرجعيه العالمي
للغاز الطبيعي المساله في المقابل طالبه
عده دول متحفظه على اي تدخل وبينها
المانيا وهولندا والنمسا بوضع ما بالغه
الشده لمنع اي سقف قد يتم تحديده من تهديد
امدادات الغاز لاوروبا هذا وكانت دول عده
خصوصا اليونان وايطاليا وبالجيكا اقترحت
خفض السقف الى 160 يورو للميجاوات ساعه
لكنها دول اخرى رفضت المخترع وسعت براج
الى جعل السقف عند مئتين 220 يورو
للميجارات ساعه يذكر ان اسعار الطاقه
الاستهلاكيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي ارتفعت
بما يقرب من
35% في نوفمبر مقارنه بالشهر نفسه من
العالي الماضي
وسط الخلافات بشكل تحديد سعر سقفي اسعار
الغاز والخشيه المستمره من شتاء قاس قامت
الدول دول الاتحاد الاوروبي بخطوات لبدا
مخزوني الطاقه في منتصف سبتمبر بلغت
احتياطات هذه البلدان
48% وهو مستوى يكفي لاشهر عده من
الاستهلاك في حين تجاوزت نسبه التخزين في
عدد من الدول الاوروبيه نسبه 80% واقتربت
من 90% كما هو الحال بالنسبه لفرنسا
وايطاليا والمانيا و بولندا والدنمارك
وتشيك واسبانيا والسويد وتبقى بعض دول
اوروبا الشرقيه بعيده عن هذا الهدف مثل
التي بلغت 65% فقط وكذلك الوضع في النفس
وفي المجر وفقا دراسات فان الخيار الوحيد
امام الدول الاوروبيه لتجاوز الاعتماد على
الغاز روسي هو خفض الاستهلاك الاوروبي
بنسبه تتراوح ما بين 10 و15 في المئه اما
المانيا فسيكون عليها خفض استهلاك الغاز
بنسبه 20% خلال الاشهر السته المقبله
لتجاوز هذه لتجاوز هذه الازمه لم يكون
تخزين دول الاوروبيه للغاز بالمهمه السهله
بل كلف ميزانيه الحكومات الاوروبيه سبعين
مليار دولار مقارنه مع اثنين 10 مليار او
فقتها اوروبا لتخزين الغاز خلال العام
الماضي حول هذا الملف ارحب بضيفي من
بروكسيل ماركو همم جولي وهو خبير سياسات
الطاقه في كليه بروكسل للحكم والمستشار
السابق للسياسات الطاقه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي سيد ماركو لنبدا لمساله امكانيه
الوصول الى اتفاق بين دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي فيما يتعلق بتحديد
تقف لاسعار الغاز هل هذا وارد بعد هذه
المغله
المقاربه العامه الان تم الاتفاق عليها
ونقطه الخلاف المتبقيه هي مستوى او ال سقف
اذا هناك سياسه لاحتواء
الاسعار وايضا امن الطاقه واا تحت مستوى
معين قد نخاطر بامن الطاقه بالنسبه الى
المواقف لا تزال متباعده ولكن على الاقل
يمكن التوصل الى تنازلات الرمزيه حل وسط
رمزي بنسبه الى مستويات ليس بالضروره ان
تكون مهمه ولكن طبعا هناك الكثير من
الدراما السياسيه المرتبطه
بعمليه تحديد السقف السقف الاسعار
وبالتالي يجب على الدول الاوروبيه ان تتفق
على تحديد سعر كيف هل هذا الاجراء سيد سيد
ماركو يتعلق فقط بالغاز الروسي او بكل
الغاز المنقول الى اوروبا عن طريق
الانابيب
السعر يرتبط
بالغاز او معدل السعر الذي يصل فيه الغاز
الى اوروبا وهذا تحدث فيه عن العقود بعيده
الامد الاتيه من روسيا او الغاز الروسيه
في هذه الحاله ولكن ايضا في الوقت نفسه
نتحدث عن الغاز الموجود في الاسواق الان
وبالتالي نتحدث عن تحديد السقفلي
الغاز المستورد
شكرا لك من بروكسيل ماركو جيولي خبير
سياسات الطاقه في كليه بروكسل الحكم
والمستشار السابق لسياسات الطاقه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه وهذا موجز
لاهم الانباء قبل الانتقال الى الجوله
الرياضيه في يوميات المونديال قال مسؤولون
امريكيون ان واشنطن تضعوا اللمسات الاخيره
على خطط لتزويد اوكرانيه بالصواريخ
باتريوت للدفاع الجوي وقال المسؤول ان
واشنطن قد تعلن ارسال هذه الصواريخ خلال
الاسبوع الجاري
افادت صحيفه بولتكون نقلا عن برقيه لوزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه الى اداره بعيدا تواجه
صعوبات في تتبع مال المساعدات الماليه
والعسكريه التي تقدم لاوكرانيا
نقل موقع اكس يوصل الاخباريه عن مصادر
بانه هناك ضبوطا غربيه على الامين العام
للامم المتحده انطونيوغتيراش لنشر
المفتشين في اوكرانيا للتحقق من استخدام
روسيا لمسيره ايرانيه الصنع فيها هجماتها
على اوكرانيا وياتي هذا في وقت ترفض فيه
روسيا اي تحرك لمجلس الامن في هذا الاتجاه
امهل رئيس حركه حماس في قطاع غزه يحيى
السنوار اسرائيل وقت المحددا لاتمام صفقه
تبادل الاسرار وفي كلمه بمناسبه الذكرى
الخامسه والثلاثين لتاسيس الحركه هدد
السنوار باغلاق ملف المفاوضات للابد
وايجاد سبل الاخرى اذا استمر في المواطنه
هذا وعرضت وحده الظل التابعه لكتائب
القسام الجناح العسكري لحركه حماس سلاح
الجندي الاسرائيلي هادار جولدن جولدن
الاسير لدى القسام منذ عام 2014
في اشاره الاتفاق الايطاليه التي وقع في
الخامس من الشهر الجاري في السودان قال
رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان انه ليس هناك تسويه سياسيه
بالمعدن الذي فهمه البعض وشدد البرهان في
خطاب امام افراد من القوه المسلحه على
ضروره الا تحاول اي جهه ان تخطفها الاتفاق
الايطالي لمصلحتها الذاتيه
ومن جهاته قال الناطق باسم الاليه ثلاثيه
ممثله الاتحاد الافريقي بالسودان محمد
بلعيش ان بعض الاطراف في السودان تهدد
باسقاط الحكومه القادمه قبل تشكيلها وحذر
مما سماه الاقصاء السياسي
اعلن رئيس الامريكي من خلال منتدى الاعمال
ضمن القمه الامريكيه الافريقيه بواشنطن عن
استثمارات امريكيه جديده في افريقيا
تعزيزا للشراكه وسيعرض بايدو دعما امريكيا
لزياده دور الاتحاد الافريقي يشمل تخصيصه
تمثيل الدائم له في مجموعه دول العشرين
كتابه الحصاد شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه
الى اللقاء باذن الله
[موسيقى]